Every organism we know needs water to survive - it's a reason
Makes us look for it with the utmost effort on the other planets in the universe, and consume it continuously
And my day here on the surface of the globe. What can happen to your body if you stop drinking water?
Of course, when we say "water" we include all fluids that contain water - such as
Juices, soft drinks or tea. Such as the desire to breathe oxygen, thirst is the survival instinct
H2O is the most molecule in the human body and constitutes an average of 65%
Of the adult human body. As a universal solvent, carries nutrients and hormones in the body, coordinates
Body temperature, supports the joints and moisturizes the eye. The body produces
L of urine daily, and a liter and a half lose with the process of breathing, sweating and ... defecation
It is therefore necessary for the body to replace these fluids.
The thirst center in the brain is present in the "hypothalamus" and is continuously used
Vascular stimuli to control the amount of sodium and other substances in the body
For example, if you are sweating profusely, the amount of blood and pressure decreases.
The brain discovers this change and stimulates the desire to drink something, now! what happens
If you did not stop this thirst?
Primary signs of dryness are dry mouth followed by urine color shift
Darker and stronger color, where the body tries to maintain more fluid.
H2O deficiency affects the brain You may feel a mild headache and a slow response time
And a decrease in pain. In fact when they are dry, the brain tissue shrinks
In a study to monitor
The same task requires more brain effort and oxygen in dry objects compared to wet objects.
After a day or two without fluids the body stops urinating, problems swallowing
Suffering from muscle spasm and possibly feeling nauseous, after all this the body can survive
Longer than non-food, and attention in digestion is not a priority at this stage
In the end, the victims may be delirious with severe weakness in brain function,
Interesting studies monitor older patients with hallucinations, many of whom have found
Suffer from chronic drought in the first place, after a longer period without water
The blood stops flowing into the skin, limiting the loss of heat but increasing
Body temperature center. This can lead to a bluish gray swab to your skin. After 3-5 days without water
The body begins to stop the organs and finally the brain
Of course, unlike the oxygen we breathe abundantly, only 2.5% of the Earth's water
Most of which are reserved for glaciers, ice caps and subterranean lakes known as aquifers,
Making less than 1% available for drinking and the majority of this water used for growing crops
Approximately 500 billion liters of fresh water is used daily for agriculture
In the United States only, with another 500 billion liters used to cool electricity plants
As drinking sources increasingly pollute, more than 783 million people are on the ground
They do not have the ability to get fresh water
Scientists around the world are trying to find solutions to this problem, from attempts
To remove salt from ocean water, take advantage of groundwater and create
Water purification system. If we look at space, NASA has developed a technique for astronauts
The urine turns to more fresh water than we drink on the ground. But we can not
We rely on technology and science only, perhaps the solution depends on us as creatures to understand
And contribute to the global water crisis.
If you want to help with the task of ending the world thirst, participate in (World Water Day)
On 22 March. There are many wonderful projects, such as Water.org
Or even the wonderful UNICEF application that donates a day of fresh water
Every 10 minutes you leave your phone. We will leave links in the description box for the two projects
For other water charities, a small investment makes a big difference
We will donate the full income of this video to a nearby water project named
(Morocco is five villages) so we thank you for your support and watching. Subscribe to the channel for more scientific sections per week !!